viens sur toi labyrinthe juste et tendre et
florissant tu pleures attention attention
garde ta garde injuste ne laisse personne voler
ne laisse personne voler ton amende
car quand tu vas bien rater vite et partir
tu peux faire plus pour toi et là
remplacer là où ton amende était  les déchets se
répandront tous sur elle avec de la place pour la laine l'argent
est un plateau en drap marron le mien est une
vigne grimpante et de vos branches négligemment
il dirait ce qu'il peut trouver
il prend ce qu'il peut trouver une robe une chanson
se tenaient à côté de trois fleurs il
m'a donné la rose le casque bleu violet -
et la rose rouge rouge un arbre l'arbre rouge rouge
rose mais je me sens tellement le rosier rouge
et obtenir la façon dont tu latrines
donc le monde mon truc tu vois comment  mon
amour me glisse oh mon amour lumière en moi
allez tu es juste et sonne émerveillé l'
épanouissement tu es fier de moi où moi où
garde ton [ __ ] de ne laisse aucun homme te diriger ne
laisse aucun homme Steve
[Musique]